What's going on guys. This is Robin.
A lot of the guys have been asking for Rob pourings.
So we are going to put them on sale. I'm going to sell 20 Robb pore rings.
And I'm curious to see how many people are interested in that. Right?
How many people are actually interested in buying Rob court rings?
So I'm going to sell 20 Robin poor rings.
I'm going to have a link down in the description is going to be an email.
You are going to send a link or you're going to send an email to that email
address. You're going to title it, Rob core ring. If you title it,
anything other than that, I'm going to ignore it and I'm going to delete it.
Right? So put in rod core, ring in the subject from there,
you don't really have to type anything. You can type whatever you want. I mean,
just, you know, you cuss at me, I'm going to, I'm not, I'm gonna ignore you.
Right. But I'll just type in anything you want to do. Like Superman is amazing,
right? Like Batman sucks, whatever you want to put in there,
but it doesn't really matter to me.
And then I will randomly pick 20 of you guys. And then in turn,
I will send you a link to a website where you can buy a Rob core ring. So yeah,
hopefully you, hopefully you guys win good luck.
We're kind of testing this to see how many people actually want to buy one.
And uh, yeah, let's start the video.
What's going on guys. This is Rob and we are back with, uh, dark nights,
death metal and DC is rebooting. Well,
maybe rebooting is not the best phrase,
I guess like unreal booting on crisis thing. It's a little weird.
You guys understand what I'm talking about once we get to this point,
but what we're going to be doing here is,
is picking up with the Robin King after he's kind of faced off against wonder
woman and all these different poses. And it's not a very lengthy thing, right?
He kind of starts talking trash to a little bit saying that on his world,
that wonder woman led a whole bunch of the superheroes to face off against him.
And they won, right? You gave the script a huge impassioned speech. And,
and following that he actually ended up killing her,
but they gave her this kind of, uh, this metal, like for honor and courage,
they gave it to her for leading the forces against Robin King.
And then he basically booby trapped it, right? So it ended up killing her.
And then after that, the world fell to him,
but it's just kind of him talking trash to her a little bit,
kind of tormenting her. It's not super important.
What is really important here is that when they try to go after the Batman who
laughs, he basically tells the, uh, the, you know,
tells castle bat to keep them in, keep them at Bay by to keep them there.
And castle bat is an actual sentience bat right now.
One of the funny things about this,
and this is one of these things where it's a little intriguing when it comes to
death metal.
This really is a story where it's all about these different iterations of Batman
from across the dark multiverse, right? A place that,
that consists of everybody's worst fears and nightmares from the main DC
universe.
But the idea is that it's entirely possible that Batman who laughs just made
this giant castle sentience, or maybe it was always that way, right?
Batman somehow managed to merge himself into a giant castle.
And then that's just where he exists. We don't really know.
And it doesn't really matter for the most part.
None of the heroes can do anything to stop him. That, that literally the, the,
this bat just kind of starts defeating these guys piece by piece.
And in the middle of all this,
there's suddenly rescued by some person that they can't only for us to find out
that it's actually a, it's actually Lex Luther,
who showed up here with the kind of Legion of duty headquarters, right?
This floating ship from back in the day, this is old school. Those guys,
you don't know, this is O G O G like during the silver age of comics OJI, right?
It's it's super old school, but he basically kind of shows up here and says,
the important thing to understand is like,
I want you here in the hall of Duke one, because you gotta,
you gotta get out of here as fast as you can. And two,
because I have a plan for this and the kind of funny thing about this is they're
very, very wary of trusting Lex Luther and rightfully so.
You're talking about a guy who, you know,
on any given day is the arch nemesis of the world's greatest superhero.
And always trying to find a way to defeat him,
but all of this started because Lex Luther freed Perpetua,
but had it not been for him,
none of this would have been the problem in the first place,
but the response of Lex is yeah, but I've kind of learned my lesson here, right?
Like I've learned, I've understood. I understand the mistake that I,
I made him doing all this. So it's important.
You guys trust me because this is basically the end of the day.
And I have a plan to stop Perpetua once. And for all,
you also see a fight kind of being instigated between Perpetua and the Batman
who laughs. This is not an overly important thing.
It's really just kind of like,
you know how it is a end up fighting in the first place that he basically tracks
her down and says like, I'm going to kill you. Right?
And then I'm going to take your power.
And then I'm just going to recreate all of existence in my own image,
basically bring the dark multiverse ended up positive multi-verse than just make
everybody's life awful. Right. That's kind of his whole stance here.
The important thing is when the fight begins,
that's when Lex says the clock is now ticking,
but the countdown timer has now begun.
And when he kind of kinda hits out here is he says the whole purpose of the
Batman who laughs the whole goal of this guy is to basically use all the
fears that everybody here has and turn them into something tangible, right?
Because the dark multi-verse is kind of this intangible thing that exists out
there, right? It's this intangible concept that you can travel to. Right?
But most people out there are blissfully unaware of it, right.
They just kind of assume that like their worst fears or their worst nightmares,
just kind of, you know,
dissipate out there into the ether or they exist only in their subconscious,
in the form of their dreams. And that's it, right? That's,
that's really all that ever really happened. The reality is they become worlds.
They become quite literally worlds that you can go to. And so the whole idea,
this is those worlds are going to become our world, right?
It's going to become the DC universe there and everything they know here is
going to be matter is going to be replaced with these dark and twisted versions.
And so what he says is that at the moment,
the Batman who laughs only has a handful of these baby worlds, right?
These worlds that he's creating based on people's dark experiences, right?
Because it takes time to move the dark multi-verse into the positive multi-verse
right. And it's not really just kind of moving it. That's what Barbados did,
right?
It's not really dragging the positive multi-verse down into the dark multiverse
or anything like that. It's creating literal worlds.
And it's important thing to understand because what it establishes here is that
despite having the powers of document Hatton and being able to use them to their
full totality, there's still limits on what he can do.
And that's one of the big differences, I think, between Marvel and DC, right?
That if this was like a Marvel comic story,
like you just have Batman who laughs snaps his fingers and just some leaves,
all the worst things in existence that I'll just manifest instantaneously DCS.
It's a lot more grounded when it comes to their flights of fancy and those crazy
stories and wonky abilities.
And everything's like that you'll never really see like a Franklin Richards type
character or like a beyond her or a molecule man, you've seen analogs to them,
but you won't really see a character with a level of power that high up on in DC
being used in that way. People will have that kind of power,
but it's not like you'll have a situation where like specter gets off.
So he just walks out and just snapped his fingers and half the life in the
universe vanishes.
And so what you end up having here is this kind of discussion where he says
this, this proposition that he has as is not that they think big,
but that they think small, right?
They think on the small scale and kind of work their way backwards.
And that's what makes them so interesting is because where you have this great
big, huge exposition offered by Lex, what are you kind of does?
Is he said that in his younger years, he grew up in T grew up in Smallville,
right? This is kind of an old school origin from back in the day.
And it's basically remained steadfast ever since,
but Lex Luther grew up in Smallville, right?
He grew up in a place that was literally dedicated to the idea of being small.
And it always fascinated him, this idea that you had this great, big, huge,
expansive universe out there that in the beginning, there was the big bang,
right?
Just a singular coalescence of energy that basically reached a kind of critical
mass through gravity and exploded,
outward giving birth to everything that we know that came into existence.
And that was fascinating for him. Now,
he he's saying that really more from a human perspective as the reader,
we know there were a lot of other working parts that were going on, right?
The presidents and Perpetua and the people who sit Perpetua,
different things like that. So we know there's a lot more to it than that,
but it all started with a big bang.
And it was fascinating because what ended up happening is that his home life was
exceedingly abusive.
And what he ended up doing was actually going out to the planetarium all the
time.
But the person who would play the entire sequence actually ended up playing it
backwards.
And it started with the end of the universe and went back to its very beginning
and it scared the heck out of him. Right?
Because it basically established this idea in the mind of Lex that everything
dies, right.
That it's inevitable that everything is going to end then in some form or
fashion, everything that was will die again. And he told his dad that, right.
And his dad kind of reiterated. Yeah.
Like everything out here will come to an end. Right.
He was kind of a Dick to him and said like, go make something of yourself,
you know? But it was like everything that,
that exists will inevitably come to an end. And that's the response of Lex here.
His whole idea is we keep thinking about this from the perspective of it started
with a big bang or starts with this event.
And then it turns into something bigger.
Let's kind of trace this to really kind of the end result and work our way
backward. Right? Like we're at the end game right now. Right.
So instead of asking what comes next, let's ask what came before?
How did we get to this point? Not even just in terms of me and Perpetua,
but everything that came before, right? He's talking about crises events.
He's talking about the event,
the crisis events that came before and he even references this, right?
He says that in terms of all this crisis energy that we have,
it's born of all of our fears, right? All of our, our current concerns,
our worries, different things like that.
Krona wanted to look into the past and see the very beginnings of the universe,
its creation,
which led to basically the whole concept of the anti-modern or at least that was
the old school story from back in the day.
And the reality of this is that it was fear that led to that. Or it was a,
it was curiosity or some kind of negative emotion that led to that, right.
That led to those sequence of events.
And you see it over and over and over again, right? Zero hour, crisis, and time.
The fear of how Jordan you go into infinite crisis, the fear of Superboy prime,
you go into final crisis, the death of dark side.
You see like all of these things kind of playing out in such a way to where
every crisis event is rooted in negative emotions.
And so his idea is what if we use it, we have a kind of energy that's connected,
right? That brings us together.
What if we trace this back to its root and we undo it, right?
We literally undo the first crisis. If we undo that,
then every crisis coming after will effectively cease to exist. Right?
It'll never happen.
What's happening here is that through Scott Snyder in writing this story,
DC is in effect going back and undoing every single prices event that they've
had. And he tells this to wonder will more.
She says that initially she used anti-crisis energy against Perpetua and it
didn't work prices. Energy was far more powerful. The responsive Lex is no,
it wasn't used to come to your fear. If you had actually stood fast with that,
that anti-crisis energy you were using, you would have overcome her,
but you would have overtaken Perpetua, but instead you were governed by fear.
And in your fear, she got the upper hand,
she tricked you and she basically duped you into effectively losing the fight.
The other part of this is we end up learning a few things.
One Batman's debt that end's been dead ever since the beginning of the story now
with something that we kind of believed because we had never officially been
told that, but it looked to be the case, right?
Like you have the whole collapse. You had Batman who looked like he died,
but inexplicably,
he just came back and we assumed that it was just because he's Batman, right.
Anxious, too popular to kill off. You know,
like it's just one of those kinds of hand-wavy things.
Like how did Batman get back here on Batman comics? You know,
and that's kind of what we attributed it to the reality of this is at Batman's
always been dead. And that's why he uses the black lantern ring.
It's the only way for him to continue existing in his current form.
Superman was bathed in the pools of dark side and is basically a,
he's a force of dark side. Now there's no taking him back to what he was before.
There's no undoing that in effect of the Trinity wonder woman is the only one
who's actually still alive and in her current form. And so it was,
it's kind of nuts here because it's a way to effectively undo everything that's
happened, going all the way back to the beginning.
Now that was initially the purpose of DC rebirth was to kind of take the things
that worked and the things that didn't work.
The reality is that this story is probably about four years behind the curve.
If I'm being honest with you guys,
it's about a little over four and a half years later than we expected it to be.
But it kind of makes sense because if DC rebirth served the purpose of figuring
out what worked and what didn't work,
bringing back some things and so on and so forth,
then it would take time to figure that out. Right? It's one thing to say,
everybody wants to see the red-haired Wally West come back.
So we'll bring him back. It's another to say, like,
what else do people want to see return?
And now that we've had the last four and a half years,
and we kind of have a general idea of what it is that people want DC can now fix
all that. And that's literally what Lex tells wonder woman,
like what's going to happen here is you're going to,
you're going to perform this act.
Things are going to go back and you're basically going to re restore everybody's
memories.
You're going to restore everyone's memories back to the way they were before,
essentially before the events of flashpoint. Now, again,
that in combination with undoing,
all the crises basically seems to mean that what DC's doing is eliminating all
the different prices, events,
and all the reboots and all the wreck cons and all the reworkings and kind of
seeming to start back during the silver age and just sort of calling it a day
and taking all the things that have worked now and all the things that worked
during the silver age and all the things that worked after crisis on infinite
earths and all the things that worked after zero hour and after infinite crisis
and after final prices, all those things that seem to work,
it's all being consolidated into a singular timeline. Now,
the question that you have to ask here is,
are we going to get new origins because to do something this big,
you can't really just do this and then leave things the way they are.
Or you can tell a series of stories, belonging to characters,
kind of reworking things, and then point back to a particular story, right?
Just have some little asterisk down there, see Superman secret origin,
number one by Jeff Johns. If you want to know Superman's origin,
we don't really know. We do know that that DC is doing their great big,
huge event. I think in January or whatever it is,
where we get like future state. Like we know we're getting that now,
whether or not this leads into that,
or some kind of an event's going to take place between now and then not a
hundred percent sure as far as I gather future state deals with the future of
everything else, right.
Doesn't really deal with the characters in the here and now it's just kind of
the next generation of heroes.
So I don't really know exactly how these things are going to tie together.
But the important thing here is that because earth zero is kind of the focal
point, right?
The prime point by which the dark multi-verse exists and the way in which, uh,
basically the Batman who laughs is creating all these different worlds.
Then there's only one way to stop that if the Batman who laughs ability to
create nightmarish worlds stems from the main DC universe and from earth
specifically, the only way to fix that is to destroy it.
And so what you end up getting is,
is basically wonder woman who grabs Lobo and says, okay,
I'm going to need your blood. And then with your originator of healing factor,
we're going to create more of you. But we're going to duplicate you,
which is really a power that Lobo has. If you were to slice off a finger,
a Lobo could grow from that finger, right?
That's one of the reasons why Lobo is kind of intriguing,
he's Wolverine to the most extreme degree,
but you literally have Superman who goes to like all these different villains
who are out there, go select joker. He goes to granny, goodness, right?
He goes to cyborg, Superman, Hank Henshaw, to a lot of these forces out there.
And they're like, so what do you want us to do?
Like band together and save the world. He's like, no, I want you to destroy it.
And that's what they do with wonder woman's army of Lobo's with the diary of
Hank Henshaw,
which wonder woman needs in order to achieve all this information to pull off
this task with Superboy prime, with Hank Henshaw, with bizarro, Superman,
himself, with Sonesta arrow and the atrocities and star Sapphire,
like all these lantern cores out there using like swamp thing using, uh,
using black Adam with all their forces, they're going to obliterate the world,
right? They're going to destroy the world.
They're going to destroy all life on the planet and just leave it as an empty
husk, right? By killing everybody on earth,
which is a pretty drastic except to make by killing everybody on earth.
This basically means that in turn the Batman who laughs cannot create any more
dreams, he can't create any more dream world, the number of worlds he has now,
that's where it stops. Now the other question to ask here is,
is there a little bit of a, of a,
a kind of a thing about this that doesn't make any sense? And the answer is yes,
the reality is that what we've seen so far or the various nightmares world
belonging to these superheroes. But as we know with the DC, multi-verse,
it's an infinite number of universes where the dark multi-verse is an infinite
number of dark universes. And so for every possible scenario,
the Superman can envision being the worst case scenario.
There's an infinite number of situations for that, right? Like say for example,
that Superman ends up becoming dark side, right? That's the most obvious one to,
to go, right? The dark side and fact Superman and takes over him, right?
There's an infinite number of possibilities based on that one thing.
What if he decides to conquer every world except earth?
What if he destroys earth? What if he gets his hands on the anti-life equation?
What if he doesn't get his hands on the anti-life equation?
There's an infinite number of possibilities there.
And so the reality is so long as life exists,
even if it's just on earth and in the form of this ragtag band of heroes.
So long as there a [inaudible] life in the universe,
there can be dark multi-verse worlds.
And so it doesn't really stand a reason here that it can kind of be cutoff in
that way. But that kind of seems to be the line of logic that we're going with.
That seems to be the direction that DC is going in.
And maybe I missed something, but in my mind,
it can't really seem to work that way. Right. That for any scenario,
there's an infinite number of possibilities.
It's the basis behind branch universe theory and how Marvel and DC handle their
alternate realities. And so of course,
what the destruction of all the life on the world perpetual was like,
what in the heck is going on? Or at least, you know, that man who laughed,
I was like, what's going on? And then of course he tries to leave perpetual,
grabs him, snatches him back and says, Nope,
you and I are going to finish this fight here.
And so with what's left of these various superheroes, it's like, okay.
And it's not just a, a band of like seven guys.
It's seemingly all the superheroes and all the supervillains on earth that
haven't died. So like all the major players, the, the suicide squad,
the justice league, teen Titans, um, let's see like doom patrol,
I think is on there.
There's some alternate reality versions of superheroes that we're aware of.
Right? So like you have the multi-vessel justice league,
you've got a handful of other heroes who were here.
The funny thing about this is that this is very much a crisis event and it's
high time DC start calling it that, right. We know it is like, we've been,
we've known this for a long time.
This is very indicative of prices on infinite earths. And in fact,
given all the various tie-ins here,
which you had unofficial tie-ins to the crisis event, but given like all the,
all the tie ins here, it's a much bigger version of crisis on infinite earths,
but that's what this is. And so with this happening, basically,
you kind of get this, this sort of a theorial void that begins to open up.
And it allows all these, these, you know,
worlds that Batman who laughs has been created to come pouring in right to come
flying in towards the superheroes.
And that's when the question's asked how many worlds do we have coming here?
Because right now they can only really see three. And it's like, okay,
we've got about three worlds coming. Right. You got one with wonder woman.
You've got one with, you know, it looks like a dark version of the specter.
Right? You've got another one with some guy who looks wild.
I don't even know who that is. Right. But like, from there, it's like,
it's a lot more than five. It's more than five it's dozens, right?
Dozens and dozens of dark multi-verse worlds.
And ultimately it doesn't look like the heroes are going to be able to survive
this whole thing, which begs the question.
How could they possibly come out on top?
And I am excited to see how this whole thing ends. Well, that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the rod,
port, you guys enjoy this video. Make sure you drop a light.
We'll catch you all later.